I have another book coming out finish my
second book that's a lot of work it is a
lot of myself when I can read a book
these days but to sit down and write a
book that's very impressive
yeah I really enjoy it I truly do I I
have a lot of comedian friends that
wrote one book and they're like I'm
never doing that again
but I like the ritual of it I like being
home I like taking you know and stand-up
you write stuff and you it's all quick
and edit down as quick as shortly short
as possible but with a book you can like
really expand it and I'm off the road
and I'm home and I'm baking bread and
I'm writing my book and like all right
I'll get tired and then I go in there
and I tend to the dough and then I come
back and I write some more I know it
sounds hilarious but it's it's a small
little ritual that really made my life
better
it truly did it's also like you're
living 600 years ago I do I go down I
scratch a little in my scroll and then I
I tend to the wheat right and then I go
back in a little more in my scroll in
the week and it's like welcome to
Assyria right and then you know when I
get tired of my chores I go down and
visit the cobbler and some butter and
come back to the estate but I really
that's where the whole actually in in
all sincerity I really that's where the
whole theme for my special came from I
just you know I feel like we're being
inundated with this feeling that we're
not doing enough and there are our life
is is something small and useless if it
doesn't compare to what you see online
with people and jets and live in these
fabulous lives which is all an illusion
they're posting their best moments with
a filter to make you feel shitty yeah
right that's what they're doing so you
have to realize like a simple life is
what wins yeah and when I started just
writing more and literally baking bread
I was like this is good stuff this is
what a life is a life isn't all this
fake stuff on online this is just these
small pleasures of life and that's where
the whole theme of the special and the
book came and the book is called you're
doing great you're doing great and other
reasons to stay alive that's very good I
still think if either one of us had that
jet we'd drop the breads
fast yeah I would like my a-hole out for
a private jet
I'd be like bread Schmidt let's go you
know they have bread on the Jack yeah
and cocaine